[Music]
Michael Douglas gets real about his sons
drug addiction battle he's grown up a
lot I think he
fortunately maybe needed this to really
see the new life that he's got ahead of
him
Cameron Douglass completed a seven-year
prison sentence for drug possession in
2016
now his oscar-winning father is opening
up to the Radio Times about that time in
a transcript obtained by the Daily Mail
Michael said quote my son struggle was a
nightmare it was stressful for all
involved very painful and difficult
adding I'm happy to say he's in
wonderful shape now I can be more happy
since Cameron's released from prison the
39 year old has turned his life around
pursuing an acting career and welcoming
his first child just one year post
incarceration I'm really looking forward
to it and I think you know it's going to
be you know more inspiration and drive
to to really try to put a nice life
together
for my daughter and it's a new role
Michael is thrilled about - he made me a
grandfather I don't know whether to kill
him or blue eyes the most beautiful
little girl
and it's just great to see him be such a
great father
[Music]
[Applause]